[موسيقى]
قبل سبعين عاما لم يكن كثيرا عدد الذين
شاهدوا مباشره لحظه تتويج ملك لبريطانيا
لكن انظار العالم تتجه الى احد اقدم
التقاليد الملكيه في العالم الحديث بمراسم
وتفاصيل ستخرج مجددا من خزائن وسجلات
البروتوكولات لتكون مشهدا لافتا يدوم نحو
ساعتين
[موسيقى]
التتويج هو جمله مراسم واجراءات تدور حول
تثبيت الملك والاعتراف والشرعيه في مشهد
انتقال التاج رمزيا وفعليا يمتزج فيها
البعد الديني والتاريخي بالتقاليد الملكيه
المتوارثه منذ نحو من الف عام تولى تشارلز
العرشه بمجرد وفاه والدته قبل ثمانيه اشهر
لكن التتويج خطوه مهمه ترمز الى بدايه
عهده الملكيه لمسافه اقل من كيلومترين
ونصف سينطلق الموكب من قصر باكنج هام الى
كنيسه ويست مونستر سيستقل الملك تشارلز
عربه ليوبيل الماسي لا لعربه الذهبيه
الملكيه العريقه هناك سيحضر الفاني من
قاده العالم وكبار الشخصيات والمسؤولين
وبهم تمتلئ الكنيسه في ساعتها القصوى
وفيها ستبدا الاجراءات الفعليه للتتويج من
خمس مراحل
يقدم الملك الى الراعي وتقليد يعود الى
العصور الانجلوساكسونيه قبل اكثر من الفعل
سيقف احد كبار الاساقفه الى جانب كرسي
التتويج معلنا ان تشارلز هو الملك
[تصفيق]
يهتف الحضور بعدها بان يحفظ الله الملك
وتعزف الابواق بعد كل هتاف
[موسيقى]
بعد ذلك يتلو كبير الاساقفه قسم التتويج
ثم يطلب من الملك ان يؤكد التزامه
بالقانون وتعاليم الكنيسه الانجليزيه
يجلس الملك على كرسي التتويج كي يمسح
بالزيت للتاكيد على المكانه الروحيه للملك
الذي يعد ايضا راس الكنيسه الانجليزيه
يمسح كبير الاساقفه راس الملك وصدره ويديه
بعلامه الصليب بزيت خاص قادم من القدس
[موسيقى]
عندما يرتدي الملك تاج القديس ادوارد
للمره الوحيده في حياته يعني ذلك حرفيا
لحظه التتويج هذا التاج مصنوع من الذهب
ونادرا ما يخرج من برج لندن الذي يعتبر
قلعه تاريخيه ومن اهم الحصون في العالم
يوضع التاج على راس الملك تشارلز اقل من
ساعه ويعاد الى مكان حفظه في البرج في
انتظار تتويج الملك المقبل
ستشمل المرحله الاخيره جلوس الملك على
العرش اخر المراسم الكنسيه يشمل مشاركه
الملك والملكه في المناوله وهي مرحله
الرئيسيه بها يكتمل اي قداس في الكنيسه
يخلع الملك تشارلز تاجر القديس ادوارد
ويضع على راسه تاج الامبراطوريه ينضم الى
الموكب الذي سيغادر كنيسه وسط مانستر
بينما يعزف النشيد الوطني هكذا يستكمل
الجانب الديني والتاريخي لمراسم التتويج
على عرش بريطانيا ستشهد الملكه كامله
مراسم تنصيب اقل زخمه يعود للملك والملكه
القرينه الى قصر باكنجها من الطريق نفسه
الذي سلكاه نحو الكنيسه ثم في القصر ومن
على شرفته يشاهد الملك تشكيلات جويه لخمس
دقائق بها تنتهي احتفالات التتويج الرسميه
في التكاليف الامنيه يتوقع ان يشارك قرابه
اربعه الاف من افراد القوات المسلحه في
تامين الاحتفالات اما التكاليف الماديه
فعلى الرغم من عدم اعلان قصر باكنج ه ام
او الحكومه البريطانيه عنها يقول خبراء
بالعائله المالكه انها ستبلغ نحو 125
مليون دولار بهذه الترتيبات يصبح تشارلز
الملكه البريطانيه الاربعين منذ عام 166